Moving on to your content workflow inside of Unreal Engine, the things I want to cover
here are working with the assets, so whether they're ready-made assets or custom assets,
importing FBX files and importing Datasmith files as well as the static mesh editor.
So a few useful shortcuts and hotkeys for viewport navigation inside of Unreal Engine
might be useful to either screenshot or just write some of these down.
Again, you'll probably get very familiar with Navigator Unreal pretty quickly, but these
are just some good navigation options to use when interfacing with Unreal Engine.
So when we're talking about readily available data, we have a starter content that's built
into the engine.
Now when we were creating these project templates before in the previous slides, there is an
option to include starter content or not include starter content.
So if you do include starter content, it comes with a whole bunch of assets that you can
use and edit in any way you like, and it contains a selection of sample assets such as meshes,
materials, textures, etc. to get you started.
These are all included within Unreal Engine, and they can be added when you create the
project and can also be added to the project at a later time.
So again, if you don't select that tick box that says include starter content, you can
add these at a later point.
Again, as we were referring to when we were talking about templates and, you know, maybe
selecting a template and you wanting to change certain configurations of the template, you
can still do that.
It just takes a long, it's more of a roundabout way of doing it.
We also have the marketplace, which we mentioned in the Epic Games launcher at the start of
this course.
Commercially available asset data, even though it contains lots of free packs.
So you can download marketplace packs from your vault and add them to any of your Unreal
Engine projects.
So once you actually have found a marketplace asset, you can either just click add to project
from directly in the marketplace or when you're in your library, you'll see all the packs
that you previously downloaded or purchased and you can add those to the project at any
point.
So it's a really good way to just pull apart other people's content and figure out how
certain people have approached different things.
We also have Quixel Bridge inside the engine.
So this is free data accessible directly from the engine.
You can see on the top right here, we have an option on the drop down to go directly
to Quixel Bridge.
So there's an enormous library of assets, 3D assets, materials, textures, and you can
use them effortlessly in your projects.
And when we talk about custom content, a few things to do before you export from your DCC
app.
So you want to make sure you use descriptive names for objects and materials, just keeping
things really organized.
When we talk about things like collisions and hierarchies, it's just really, really
good practice to keep things.
Whatever naming convention you're using, just keep things organized and combine meshes wherever
possible.
Make sure all the meshes are clean and consistent with proper UVs.
When we're talking about clean, we're making sure that all our geometry is correct.
We've not got any inside faces or flip normals or anything like this.
Just make sure everything's clean and consistent with your proper UV layout and pay attention
to objects that have been scaled, especially in a non-uniform way.
Everything ideally is just a scale of 1, 1, 1 inside your DCC app.
And then when you import it, everything works as intended there.
Keep the scene as close to the origin of the world, which is 0, 0, 0 as possible.
As scenes move further away from world 0, the greater possibility for rounding errors
to happen.
So you may get graphical glitches and it's hard to reproduce those bugs, especially when
you're not sure what's causing it.
So again, when we talk about our custom content, just maintaining this good workflow is really
important.
And then check your pivot points and ensure they're in the right place.
So whether they've been center pivoted or maybe you have some building structures that
need their pivots on a certain corner to snap together, just make sure you're checking
all your pivot points before you export.
We can update pivot points in Unreal Engine, but it's better to have the actual data coming
in as you intend it to be.
So which road to take, whether we take FBX or Datasmith?
With FBX, mind your system units.
If you are planning to use FBX workflows, we use centimeters as a base unit in the DCC
app to match Unreal Engine's unit system so that your scales aren't off here.
And make sure your objects are centered in the world like we mentioned before with 0,
0, 0.
With Datasmith, you need to ensure that you have the Datasmith exporter for your DCC of
choice.
So you can find a link here to all the different plugins that are available and just make sure
you download the relevant one for the software that you're using.
Don't worry about your DCC C units.
The Datasmith converter already takes care of everything on that front and it reads and
ports CAD formats natively.
Datasmith also works well with fully assembled scenes and large data sets and it's compatible
with more material types than FBX can provide.
And we can also export full scenes or partial ones.
The simple export UI defaults to export where it's only visible on the screen.
So again, when you're making your choice between FBX and Datasmith, it's worth keeping those
things in mind.